it just never stops
[Applause]
[Music]
so the first teaser for the Disney
live-action remake up Aladdin dropped
and I don't really want to talk about
that specifically but it has driven me
to the point where I realized how long
it has been since I talked about my
feelings on Disney doing live-action
remakes of their animated films so I
have talked about this before and I was
hesitant to talk about it again because
my views haven't really changed since
the last time we talked about this and I
forget how many years ago it was now I
don't think I've even broken a thousand
subscribers yet the last time I talked
about this so you know what we're gonna
talk about it again
so I am fundamentally philosophically
and severely against the entire press of
Disney making live-action remakes of
their animated films for a number of
reasons the first is that they're
failing to do what I think there is more
than ample room to do if Disney were to
be taking these things that they have
already done has animated features most
of which are considered classics if they
were to go to something like Aladdin
Beauty and the Beast Cinderella The
Jungle Book and if they were going back
to the source material and going what is
a way for us to take to tackle this
material that's different from the last
time we did it I would have zero issue
absolutely not that's more than a valid
thing to do especially considering these
folklore how much the Disney version
deviates from the original the first
that's not even to say that to do a live
actually you should keep it closer to
Richard no sure go on do your own Disney
thing just have it be a different Disney
thing than the last time you did it but
they're not doing that by and large what
they're doing is literally remaking the
same movie in live-action and I hate
this so much
first of all in my mind this entire
practice is as pointless as Gus Van
Sant's shot-for-shot remake of psycho
was it is on the same level it already
exists it's considered a classic you're
just doing it again and you're not
differentiating it and the few things
that they've done to differentiate these
things are the worst options for how to
do it now allow me to clarify a few
things I've actually not seen any of the
live-action remakes of Disney films and
I won't I don't want to watch them and I
refuse to throw money at them that's it
I know what goes on in them between
talking to people who have seen them
watching reviews of them reading
synopsis I know what goes on I know what
was different or more often than not how
little was different so depending on
which ones you you want to take a look
at some are more egregious than others
but the vast majority have been just
straight-up remakes which is
strip-mining
Disney's classics and then part of the
frustration of that is this isn't even a
matter of oh we need to bring it for a
new generation these the originals never
went away like Disney animated films are
truly timeless I remember when I was a
kid that it blew my frickin mind that
Peter Pan
Pinocchio Bambi were decades older than
I was the idea that they've been around
that long that blew my mind because they
are timeless they animation stands the
test of time
way better than
live-action despite its very nature and
so these things with a couple of
exceptions here and there have not aged
poorly and they still work as much now
as they did when they were made
so the normal you know sort of
justification for a remake up well we
need to bring it for a new generation
this generation already was watching it
like so that's gone and what I really
get annoyed about it and what I'm about
to say I fully acknowledge Disney is not
intentionally making this a text or
subtext of this entire practice but it
is an underlying thing whether they want
it to be or not which is that doing
these live-action remakes it
fundamentally undermines the art of
animation and it reinforces the
conception which is very much an
American and Western conception that
real movies are live-action and animated
movies are just for kids
now these live-action ones are still
very much kids movies but you know
they're longer they're more detailed we
go into we we fix some of the problems
with the animated ones now last time I
ranted about this about the one thing
that's different is more of these have
come out so I'm actually I feel way more
justified in my opinion now than I was
when I did the last video because last
video only a handful of things had
actually come out and this was still
largely all theoretical and a
hypothetical I ended up being right go
fergan figure I'm not actually happy
about that I would have loved to have
been wrong but let's look at the ones
that have been done so far and I'm not
gonna go blow for blow on all of these
now people have told me more than a few
times that the jungle book is the best
one of the ones that have been remade
and I don't necessarily doubt that the
approach of it looked kind of
interesting but the instant it lost me
was when I saw a trailer where they
started humming bare necessities because
bare necessities is not iconic to the
story its iconic to the Disney version
of that story which means there's strict
mining the original animated one and
that's not the only song that they took
either and know having Christopher
Walken do I want to be like you as this
weird spoken word quest Christopher
Walken esque thing doesn't make it any
better
just makes a weirder so I would say
probably that from my understanding of
what was done that's the one that was
probably the best the one that from what
I have seen and read and talked to
people about the most egregious so far
is Beauty and the Beast Beauty and the
Beast the original animated one is
arguably the best film of the Disney
Renaissance possibly even the best film
that Disney Animation Studios ever did
it is so tight and so complete and does
absolutely everything that it needs to
do in less than an hour and a half
whereas the live-action remake goes for
dang near two hours and adds nothing
that needed to be there I mean yeah I'll
steal from Lindsey Ellis on this because
she did the I think the definitive
breakdown on why all these additions
don't help which you know with her
refrain of thanks I hate it because of
all the this additional stuff they added
that and answer'd pedantic criticisms of
why didn't the people remember that
there was a palace and a king why were
the servants cursed is everything in
there a little bit like these are
questions that you could ask of the
original but not having answers to them
did nothing to diminish the original the
original worked it just did so what
we're looking at now with this Aladdin
teaser what true what kind of triggered
me was in the teaser we heard we heard
the Cave of Wonders and it is the exact
same voice I don't even think they
reused the recording because I know that
movie well enough that I I know exactly
how it sounds like I think
that they brought that actor in that
voice actor in to do it again in the
same voice and I had really been hopeful
for the elad one you know when they when
they were gonna do ethnically
appropriate casting I was like okay yeah
and you know I they lined up a whole
bunch of you know unknowns for a lot of
these parts I'm like yeah this could be
really interesting got Guy Ritchie
attachment like okay yes but then the
instant I lost interest was when they
said oh and you know we we've got these
songs and we're bringing some songs back
in doing so knows I'm like God and that
might ultimately be the capper for me on
most of these if they weren't musicals
literally recycling the same songs in a
fair number of these I'd be slightly
better disposed to them than I am but
yeah so are there any of these that I
have been okay with yeah
the ones that actually did something new
maleficent wasn't actually a great movie
I think it had an amazing first third
and couldn't stick the landing the
middle is particularly weak on that one
but Maleficent
I have no philosophical issue with
because it's doing a completely
different thing Sam was Christopher
Robin for that matter I was really
skeptical when I heard Winnie the Pooh
was on the remake docket but then once
yet actually came out haven't seen this
either but I wouldn't object to seeing
him when it actually came out turns out
that you know Chris the Christopher
Robin is not actually a remake of any of
the Winnie the Pooh stories they've done
it's an extrapolation forward and it's a
new story cool fine and Mulan I was
hopeful for because initially they said
they weren't gonna do the songs and they
weren't gonna have the dragon I know
some people like Mu Shu he's not
necessary for that story he was at
Disney ism he was the Disney sidekick
added into this story that didn't mean
whether you like him or not it he
doesn't need to be there and a very good
way to differentiate it would be to not
have him and not have the songs but last
I checked month or so ago they said oh
no we're gonna have some of the songs
and we're gonna have the Dragon
so even when for a brief period it looks
like they were going to do something new
instead they just circle back and go oh
no we'll just do the same thing again
and it is just so masturbatory and such
diminishing returns I do believe that it
honestly weakens the merit of the
originals with this kind of nonsense not
quite to the degree that if work to do a
comparison the cheap direct-to-video
Disney sequels used to I would I will
and I will cop to the fact that those I
think were more damaging to Disney
Animation overall and to those
particular stories and classics than yo
this is but this still isn't good and
now they said they're gonna remake lilo
and Stitch stitch with Y what is there
that we actually gain are people really
not able to connect anymore to something
that they love from a childhood if it
hasn't in some way been superficially
updated I still love the Disney films I
loved when I was a kid I have those I
love them
I still watch them I adore introducing
my daughter to them I don't need to see
it done again but longer and worse
because that's the other thing I don't
know anyone on any of these even the
best ones who have said it's even better
than the original like the ones that got
the warmest reaction at least from folks
I know who understand where I'm coming
from when I talk about this were
Cinderella
and the Jungle Book and I don't know
anyone who says that oh man they really
big did it better this time why are we
doing this and the epitome of
pointlessness The Lion King and again I
can appreciate the fact that this time
aside from Zazu which is gonna be John
Oliver they are going for an all-black
cast which if you're gonna set it in
Africa cool I'm down for that
but it's not really gonna be live-action
it's gonna be computer animated computer
animated it's still animation I don't
care how real it looks at least in
Jungle Book the kid was real the
pointlessness of these the fact that
other people especially people my age
continued to get really excited over
these just infuriates me and maybe I'm
just the cranky party pooping bastard
who is looking at something that other
people are enjoying going that's dumb
you shouldn't enjoy that and I don't
like to be that guy but why why why is
any of this happening and why does it
feel like I'm the only one looking at
the overall thing and going no because
it feels like if anyone else is
rejecting this they're rejecting it on
case-by-case basic not the overall thing
like the overt just know just stop none
of this is helping none of this is
better just Disney I know you're kind of
sore over the fact that 30 years ago you
used to be able and prior to that you
used to be able to re-release your
Animated Classics to theaters again
because home video wasn't all that big
of a thing yet but now it is and you
can't get away with that you tried to
with the 3d conversion for a little bit
but that didn't last like I get that you
want to keep milking these things I get
it
and I get that you figured oh well
basically just take the same script to
it in live-action it'll be great
ya know I get from a business standpoint
get it artistic standpoint how far it
didn't dare you every time I look at one
of these trailers I think maybe this
time it won't be what I'm afraid it is
but every time it has been and as a
lover of animation as someone who grew
up on these movies who still owns them
and still watches them please just stop
so those are my thoughts on the
apparently never going to end
trend of Disney remaking its animated
films in live-action remake the Black
Cauldron remake the one that what that
didn't work it wasn't good
like I dare be married in that but what
are your thoughts about it whatever they
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of buttons and links and stuff to
so you know click the buttons check out
the links there's one to the patreon if
you feel like supporting this channel
and my ability to try and make things
better in it with it whatever I'm so
check those out if you feel like if
there's a whole bunch of other links
besides but you know if you don't want
to take the time don't worry about it
because remember folks you got the
council and I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]